i mean what an extraordinary week it's
been um 40 of conservative mps voting to
say they've had no confidence in their
prime minister
do you think kirsten missed a bit of a
trick at prime minister's questions and
not really pushing that
no i thought that kiyosama at prime
minister's questions today actually
pushed the reality that people are
facing in the nhs in england unable to
get a gp
appointment the weights at a e
the cancer waiting lists that have been
going up over the past 12 years and
that's the reality people are facing
and we have a government now that isn't
dealing with those issues what we've
seen this week is a government in
absolute chaos we have 148 conservative
mps
who agree with us there's an opposition
that they've no confidence whatsoever in
the prime minister then you've got 211
conservative mps who are saying that the
prime minister's law breaking the prime
minister's contempt for people's
sacrifices during the pandemic is an
acceptable thing that they can support
what you now have is a divided
conservative party that isn't going to
be able to tackle the challenges of the
country
do you think though i mean boris johnson
argues that look
he he's got the vote out of the way he's
drawn a line under it he's got a
majority and actually you know even if
you speak to the most fierce critics
like tim lowton who just had on the
program they seem to accept the result
and do you think that he's now going to
lead the conservatives into the next
election
uh whether the prime minister leads the
conservatives into the next election uh
or not we will be making the case that
we've had 12 years of conservative
failure and looking at it from the
opposition benches this week let's not
hide from what's happened here a
majority of the conservative mps has
voted to support this prime minister
this is a prime minister whose focus is
on saving himself this is a government
we saw a document conservative mps had
put around saying that the purpose of
this government is actually to keep the
prime minister in office they are not
focused on the problem i mean to be fair
they would say that you know in just the
last few weeks they have they have
launched a bumper package to help with
the cost of living going further than
the labour party would have done uh on
uh with the windfall tax and on energy
bills so
it's not right to say that they're not
doing anything is it the conservative
party has been in power for 12 years is
tired and out of ideas it's labor that's
made the political weather it's the
windfall tax proposal that we actually
pushed for months and months and if by
the way they'd adopted it five months
ago nearly six months ago when we first
spoke about it people would have been in
a much better position now they are out
of ideas and this is a tired government
now on the 21st of june we're expecting
strikes on the trains or on the
underground network the rmt say that
it's going to be the biggest outbreak of
industrial action in the uk since 1989.
do you back the strikes
what i would like to see is a resolution
to this nobody ever wants to see strikes
nobody wants to see workers in a
position of making those sacrifices
nobody wants to see the disruption that
this is going to cause to the public and
what we need to come in there because i
mean no one would disagree that you want
to see a resolution the question is you
know where do you get that resolution if
you can't reach one would you like
strike so do you back strikes under the
current situation what i want to see is
more dialogue we've seen the three dates
that the rmt has spoken about there is
still absolutely time for dialogue that
dialogue has to take place and we can't
have either government ministers somehow
washing their hands of responsibility
about this so more dialogue does that
mean that the rmt should pause the
strikes in favor of more dialogue
because is that what you're saying but
there is still time available we're not
right up against at the moment the date
that the rmt is saying i think it's the
21st of june is the first date that
they're talking about there is time for
dialogue we need to get all the parties
around the table there needs to be the
government by the way not distracted
permanently as they are by their own
internal problems who actually take some
responsibility for facilitating these
talks and preventing those strikes from
happening i spoke to the rmt's mick
lynch on the sunday program a couple
weeks ago
he said i've seen no response from the
labour front bench that says we support
the workers in their struggles if we
just get this bland democratic party
sitting in the center of politics taking
their instructions off the daily mail to
some extent and not actually getting
behind workers struggles you have to ask
yourself why do they actually call
themselves the labour party well i don't
agree with that
interpretation we are on the side of
working people up and down the country
whether they're working in the rail
industry whether
they are in the wider public working in
many other industries what we need to
see is an actual cost of living package
we need an emergency budget we shouldn't
be having the national insurance
increase can you see why mitt lynch
thinks that the labour party is a bit
bland if you just say oh yeah we want
more dialogue but it feels like you're
not really giving a definitive answer on
what you feel about the strikes
no i i fundamentally disagree because i
think strike action is always difficult
and dialogue is the only way that you
find a solution so that's why i'm
merging that dialogue in those
particular circumstances but i don't
accept at all that what we said about
the cost of living is somehow bland it's
our campaigning on the windfall tax
that's caused the government to actually
have to adopt our policy we are the ones
calling for an emergency budget saying
there shouldn't be the national
insurance increase we're the ones who
are talking about investing a climate
investment pledge 28 billion pounds uh
each year insulating homes up and down
the country we are the party that is
putting those ideas forward do you
support the government's package on the
cost of living
uh
we've we've been very clear on things
like where the chancellor actually
reduced fuel duty that of course those
are things that we would support but the
idea that what the chancellor has put
forward is sufficient for everybody out
there is actually facing i'm afraid it's
for the birds it isn't and what the
chancellor has had to do already was to
come back when we pushed him to do so he
should come back again with an emergency
budget but with what in the the
emergency budget what specifically would
you like to see right well first of all
let's see the reversal of the national
insurance increase
let's see the chancellor of the
exchequer take away vat on energy for
example is another thing that the
chancellor could do and let's see the
chancellor as well
for once actually have a long-term plan
for tackling growth in the in the 10
years before the pandemic the average
growth per year was running at below 2
percent there needs to be a strategy for
growth in my area of international trade
by the way we see the government rushing
to complete
initial trade deals what they're not
doing and i see it because i'm out there
visiting exporters on the front line
they're not providing the support to
businesses and to exporters that they
need to actually be able to make those
trade deals work for communities up and
down the country okay thank you very
much for being on the show today uh nick
at thomas simmons there